[Musique]
tony comiti à photographier le pire est
filmé le meilleur ou inversement
devenu un des plus grands producteurs de
la télévision française voire européenne
il dit n'avoir rien prémédité car selon
lui c'est la vie qui décide pour nous
alors voyons donc en photo ce que la vie
a décidé pour lui avec ou sans filtre
[Musique]
bienvenue dans votre vie tony incroyable
et les photos de cet émouvant
ouais super mais c'est quelque chose à
chaque fois on va refaire justement le
chemin de votre vie à travers des photos
marquantes et va commencer par celle ci
le furet navy ça commence par des
parents forcément ouais donc paul comiti
mon père sylvette et sylvette committee
mon père est d'origine de serra di
scopamène neas août
il a quitté la corse jeune 16 ans pour
rentrer dans la résistance il a suivi le
général de gaulle à londres
wade suivre génère le gode d'abord il
est rentré dans les forces françaises
libres et après il a rejoint le général
de gaulle à londres et ma mère qu'il a
dû rencontrer à paris à l'époque
origines de pau dont la famille un
migrer vers l'argentine
d'où un petit peu s'ils voulaient comme
quoi les parents ça ça marque
d'où un peu mon amitié pour les pays
latino
on va se centrer un petit peu sur votre
papa pas quand il est ici mais plutôt
quand il est là quand il est là cette
photo elle est impressionnante elle est
incroyable voilà donc il s'agit là à mon
père donc a rejoint le général de gaulle
et il a assuré la protection rapprochée
du général c'était le chef de l'équipe
de sécurité rapprochée
donc il a suivi général de 1958 jusqu'à
colombie jusqu'à l'enterrement
il a protégé le général de gaulle avec
c'est qu'on les appelait les gorilles
d'ailleurs quand je remonte au village
acer il ya parfois un vieux qui
demandent ni coillte qui suit sur les
bêtises c'est tony comiti le fils du
gorille un oubli
c'est un fils du jour ils étaient les
gorilles de de gaulle très connu il
était là parce qu'il ya une photo mais
sur toutes les photos du général il est
toujours il n'est jamais loin qui
dormaient pratiquement à côté lui à
l'elysée dans les périodes difficiles
l'eau est pratiquement mon père passage
jour et nuit à l'elysée
dans l'antichambre du général la
mitraillette sur les genoux et vois pas
pas non content d'être le garde du corps
du général général le confie aussi une
audition alors à l'époque il n'y avait
pas de service de communication les
postes de service de presse il n'y avait
pas de plateaux de télévision avec des
politiques
il y avait des réunions politiques et le
général de gaulle a demandé à mon père
de fonder le service d'action civique le
sac qui s'occupait de la propagande du
général de gaulle et de la sécurité dans
les meetings politiques ou les
gaullistes allait se battre contre les
communistes c'est votre papa qui fondent
le sac
c'est mon père qui fonde le sac avec
jacques foccart qui était très proche du
général et moi j'allais à l'école parce
qu'on était sur la liste noire ou bien
évidemment de maïs mon père rentre à la
maison
il avait son 38 canon longue sous son
journal comme ça il déposait son arme
sur la bibliothèque lui demande
interdit de toucher et j'allais à
l'école avec que des gardes du corps on
était sur la liste noire de l'ol à
l'école la voici justement vous allez à
l'école a bouffé mauvais souvenir de
l'école parce que j'ai jamais rien foutu
donc c'est pas grave donc tout n'est pas
encore sain votre papa effectivement
vous grandissez cerveaux vers ces
satanés vendredi à paris mais bon comme
ça marchait pas trop à l'école on a
tenté le pensionnat donc que je me suis
retrouvé à bouvet je sais pas pourquoi
pouvait probablement mon père devait
connaître le principal de beauvais je me
suis retrouvé là où nous pensions ou ce
n'est pas un mauvais souvenir ne peut
que je foutais rien de toute façon
voilà je pensais que faire de la musique
bien sûr que votre père il n'est pas
d'accord avec ça il y faut que tu dis il
faut que j'étudie où tu tombes à quoi
sert ou le bac ou la porte où tu vas
bosser donc et vous à 17 ans vous dit
rien d'ailleurs vous faisiez et à bach -
3 à bac - 3 je rencontre une fille qui
en camargue et je les suis en camargue
ça te paraît de la mer ou là j'ai
rencontré un photographe qui s'appelait
jean françois sénéchal qui était le
photographe de manitas de plata et qui
pour gagner sa vie il faisait de la
photo stop ce qu'on appelle sur les
plages
donc il m'avait dit écoute si tu veux
apprendre voilà j'ai une idée on va on
va photographier les touristes qui
partent à cheval en promenade en forêt
le bon cheval tu fonces est une
mobylette
on développe et tu
bon la photo au retour de la promenade
et c'est comme ça je suis resté en
camargue et quelques mois sur des photos
d'une lourde est la photo de francs de
france a créé une vocation sauf que
votre papa n entend pas de cette oreille
là vous retrouve assez facilement à
l'époque il avait les moyens de vous
retrouver et en patron de la sécurité de
l'elysée elle était plutôt soft pour lui
il vous envoie il dit comme thiam la
photo et ben tiens je te trouve un stage
à france-soir de faits interpellés par
les gendarmes est ramené à paris
après j'en ai carrément ah oui quand on
bras maintenant par le sentiment 1 et
papa l'a compris ce qu'il m'a dit la
photo c'est un métier de gitans mais bon
puisque tu veux faire ça j'ai un contact
à france soir ce qu'il faut savoir qu'à
l'époque le général n'y avait pas de
service de communication donc il fallait
être bien avec la garde rapprochée pour
pouvoir faire et approcher le général et
faire les photos un peu différente des
autres donc c'est mon père qui
décideraient suivant c'est un peu le
chef de presse aussi dans la sécurité et
donc il faut qu'ils connaissaient tous
les journalistes pour a promis le
général
il fallait passer par le en tout cas par
papa donc c'était ses journalistes
s'étaient liés d'amitié avec mon père
c'était des braqueurs mon père aussi
d'ailleurs il aimait la fête
il aimait la vie et donc ses
photographes et ses journalistes
venaient souvent dîner à la maison dont
mon ami georges mesnager le pauvre qui
malheureusement est parti qui vous donne
et jean georges avait senti il était
photographe reporter un match il a
couvert le cambodge et le vietnam
l'algérie ces gens là me racontait des
histoires exceptionnelles moi j'ai goûté
j'avais 14 ans quand j'écoutais ça ça
faisait rêver ces jours-là et et puis
ménagé mais les gouttes si tu aimes la
photo faut moins qu'un appareil donc il
m'a offert un appareil nikon avec un 28
mm voilà c'est l'élément c'est dans le
métier avec un soir à france soir avec
monkey nikon et mon petit 28 mm au labo
au labo de france soir et puis les
rencontres
la deuxième rencontre avant mars quand
tu es là bas voilà ça c'est mon ami
gauche chine aussi aujourd'hui disparu
malheureusement goksin sipahioglu grand
reporter qui a couvert aussi toutes les
guerres les guerre du biafra toutes les
guerres d'afrique les guerre du vietnam
et qui a dans les années
soixante dix monté une agence de presse
qui est devenue célèbre cette agence
sipa press
il y avait trois agences puissante en
france gamma sygma et sipa press look
chine et turcs
il parlait avec un accent turc et avec
des turcs avant d'apprendre la photo il
fallait apprendre le turc
ces blocs sont ils nous paient jamais ou
presque pas mais ça a été un grand
patron de presse et surtout c'est lui
qui m'a appris le grand reportage
donc qu'est ce qui vous a pris la chine
c'est à dire par exemple le téléobjectif
le grand-angle la proche des gens il
passait beaucoup de temps à regarder mes
contacts
à l'époque la pellicule on faisait des
planches contacts il était là qu'au sein
et regardez dit ça c'est d'agents de
photos mais t'as pas fait couleurs gino
qui t'as perdu beaucoup d'argent
en fait c'est quoi qu'il en soit grâce à
gautschi nombre vous savez effectivement
raconté il se rend photos et puis c'est
lui qui vous envoie chili dont tout à
fait donc et bien vente raconté le chili
ça se passe dans une pièce c'est
cohérent qui vous aidera le chili vous
allez faire vos photos importante est
impressionnante mais c'est un épisode
c'est notre premier grand reportage
international en fait anonymat
[Musique]
allez donner place tony là bas
et laissez vous guider par les images
alors donc vous arrivez au chili nous en
mai 1973
vous faites votre photo depuis danger
très belles photos c'est une photo un
peu voler comme ça préféré qu'un les cas
comme ça parce que le mot il voulait pas
poser donc c'était assez rapide mais la
photo est importante
excellent à la main et nous apprenons
que il y à un stade stade de football à
santiago du chili dans lequel ils ont
enfermé plus de 1000 détenus ces détenus
on les reverra jamais ils ont fait des
grands braff dont tous sont égaux est
interdit à la presse c'est interdit à la
presse mais toute la presse demande donc
une nous mène à peu en bateau plutôt en
bus d'ailleurs qu'il nous faut monter
dans des bus et toute la journée ont
fait le tour du stade à être le bios on
s'arrête pas et on revient l'hôtel ils
nous disent non mais pas demain vous
revenez demain
et puis ça durait trois quatre joueurs
que ça et beaucoup de journalistes ont
décroché à qui l'on va faire autre chose
on n'y arrive pas on n'y arrive pas et
moi je suis resté dans ce bus avec un
autre photographe de magnum qui
s'appelait david burnett et on a vu
qu'il y avait la croix rouge qui étaient
à la sortie du stade
on s'est fait déposer en dix ans nous on
voulait voir les gens de la croix rouge
est ce que c'est possible mais allez-y
on est allé voir les gens de la croix
rouge
et là on appris que les gens de la
croix-rouge aller rendre visite aux
détenus étaient dans le ca de son des
tribunes du stade et j'ai pris une
blouse stéthoscope
j'aime bien les cas sous la blouse et
vous êtes rentré je suis rentré dans le
stade et vous avez shooter est bien
obligé on va fêter les faux c'est ça
ouais ça fait les photos voilà avec
l'armée l'armée chilienne cefeo les
carriers autres en somme dit m celle là
est celle là les terribles parce que
c'est dans les vestiaires du stade où là
ils font le tri et tous les visages que
vous voyez là on le reverra jamais un
scoop mondial c'est votre premier scoop
mondial est assez fou ces photos les
voix dans le monde entier vous êtes les
premiers et là ils vont en vouloir au
chili on va vous expulsez pratiquement
manu militari et comme vous avez de la
mémoire des années et des années plus
tard vous allez revenir faire un
reportage sur les anciens geôliers dans
notre et qui sont en liberté
on passe à autre chose enfin trouvé le
viendrait cette photo est terrible ouais
là quelques années plus tard cette fois
là une vraie histoire aujourd'hui encore
vous recevez des royalties
parce que vous êtes là bas fait cette
photo a compté nous un petit peu comment
vous avez fait cette photo ça cette
photo c'est une plante comme péguy
jacques mesrine est arrêté il est à la
santé dans le quartier de haute sécurité
qui l'a dénoncé dans son livre
l'instinct de mort et voilà donc moi je
me dis il ya une photo importante en ce
moment c'est jacques mesrine
tout le monde veut le faire encore tout
comme au chili voilà tout le monde veut
le faire sauf qu'il est en qhs à la
santé et puis j'apprends que le
directeur de la santé c'est un corse
donc je vais le voir je vais le voir je
me fais passer pour un dessinateur de
presse
il l'a pas crue du tout d'ailleurs ml
écoutes ne perd pas de temps mesrine il
sort jamais
et de toute façon qu'il ne verra pas
mais enfin bon c'est ce que tu vas
chercher pour tes pour t'éviter de
tourner en rond il est dans les
quartiers sud de la prison
donc évidemment la prison et autour de
cette prison il ya des des hlm donc gelé
dans le hlm sud
et puis je suis monté au dernier étage
et là j'ai établi une planque ce qu'on
appelle une planque dire que pendant une
semaine tous les jours avec un tel
objectif de 600 mm j'ai l'oeil sur ce
clash s voilà dix ans tous les jours
c'est toute la journée du match lens et
une planque c'est du matin au soir d'un
plan on va aller aux toilettes on va pas
bouffer on a un sens oui si on a un parc
à 6 fait froid et on a l'oeil dans le
viseur
c'est ce qu'on appelle une planque donc
voilà donc pendant une semaine bon il
sort pareil sort pas et puis un soir
j'avais passé la nuit au bus palladium
dont j'étais un peu un des piliers c'est
une boîte et en sortant vers 6 heures du
matin du bus du bus palladium tu dis
tiens j'allais voir jacques donc je suis
passé à l' agence j'ai pris mon tel
objectif
je suis retourné dans la planque est à
peine installé la petite porte s'est
ouverte et mesrine est sorti mais
j'étais à peine installé il a vu
donc dans son paysage quelque chose
n'allait pas il ya un espèce d'instinct
il a fait un pas en arrière et il a
envoyé un gardien pour voir qui j'étais
et lab ont découvert j'ai montré mon
objectif le gardien a dû lui dire
baisser un photographe
il est sorti et il a posé pendant une
minute comme ça voilà et les photos sans
sont vendus à ses chers à l'époque c'est
l'express qui l'avait acheté 20 bureaux
est quand même important à l'époque on
est en 76 et puis donc un jour j'ai reçu
un coup de téléphone de son avocate qui
n'est jacques a vu les photos il écrit
un bouquin il voudrait faire la
couverture de son livre avec avec vos
photos
j'ai dit y'a pas de soucis il montrait
aucun droit c'est gratuit pour vaincre
un jour vous abandonnez votre appareil
photo et vous passez à la caméra c'est
grâce à un journaliste de tf1 rock
pescade hier qui vous attend un petit
peu à la caméra et lui rentre avec il
vous fait un petit peu essayé la caméra
et que de rendre qui fait son reportage
est dit tiens tony au fait j'ai mis des
images de toits
voilà et vous vous découvrez finalement
le talent si avec la caméra et avec
cette caméra vous allez voyager vous
rentrez à tf1 vous avez signé un cdi et
vous devenez reporter de guerre pour tf1
c'est cela il ya une photo qui résume
peut-être votre métier à tf1 c'est celle
ci voilà on est à beyrouth la guerre la
guerre là-bas avec trois ans 2,83 à
beyrouth
vous allez passer deux ans à berlin vous
rentrerez de temps en temps à paris mais
vous passez du temps et moi en tout cas
ce qui m'a touchée c'est qu'un jour il
ya je sais pas avec qui vous travaillez
à l'époque qui vous dit tiens on va
aller quelque part et vous dites ces
plages ne sent pas expliquer moi un
petit peu tony on est invité par par les
islamistes à les filmer la prière du
vendredi dans un quartier islamistes
intégristes qui s'appelait bien la bête
qui est un quartier de beyrouth où ou
détenaient tous leurs otages
et quand on arrive sur place et j'étais
avec jean-pierre abou qui est un grand
reporter de tf1
j'ai vu j'ai vu un des barbus qui était
dans une
une des voitures qui nous espionner à
autour du bureau
j'ai dit à jean pierre lahon semble
voici le relais je le sens pas du tout
là et jean pierre m'a dit écoute on veut
quand toi tu te sens tant on se dire on
est rentré à l'hôtel
l'équipe de france 2 est arrivé ils sont
jamais revenus
c'est qu'ils ont été enlevés les
fameuses otage s'est livré pendant que
vous êtes à tf1 une rencontre marquante
est celle ci jean bertolino alors
lambert que lio c'est lui qui vous
remarque un parce qu'un jour il déjà
quand reporter et puis où j'ai vu des
images du tchad là ça a l'air
fantastique qu'est ce qu'a fait ces
images ont dû baisser un certain tony
comiti healy tony comiti viens avec moi
ils nous ont accompagnés pendant combien
d'années jean bertolino la femme disait
toujours tu passes plus devenu avec jean
que qu'avec moi pendant 17 ans on va
faire du grand reportage laisser les 17
plus belles années de votre vie en tout
cas en tant que journaliste poète et
jean-louis tf1 la perse absolument
absolument et il dit jean bertolino toi
tu sens les histoires tony et ils vous
envoient en colombie tout à fait un
bouteille en colombie vous faites une
rencontre cet homme-là donne tableau
escobar donne pas beau escobar c'est
vous qui le rencontraient on était menés
chez pablo escobar qui est en cavale
pour gribouiller que la dre la dea
church l'armée colombienne cherche le
monde entier de cherche et on a ce scoop
quoi donc on est on est amené par les
gens du cartel de nuit et quand j'arrive
dans cette hacienda où il y avait tous
ces sicario vous il y avait des armes à
la main là il était il ya un petit
bonhomme qui est la voir au fond de la
propriété
assis pour la piscine et il se lève et
vient direct sur moi et il me dit pablo
escobar tony comiti il se penche le
monorail ne dit j'aime pas les caméras
mais bon il avait envie de il avait
envie de parler il a envie de
communiquer il voulait pas donner le
scoop ni aux américains ni aux
colombiens sauf qu'ils parlent
effectivement mais vous interdise de le
d'ivoire et est ce reportage en fait il
faudra le diffuser après la mort de
pablo escobar et c'est à dire quand on
va le regarder on va le regarder à les y
faire quand quand on avait quand même un
deal avec eux c'était leur montrer le
film à savoir diffusion deal que l'on
avait oublié nous appartient donc
et puis le deal est devenu un peu
menaçant les appelle donc il a fallu
j'aille le montrer et ça n'aura pas du
tout plu donc ils nous ont menacés de
mort et quand les colombiens vos menaces
de mort voilà donc on n'a pas diffusé le
film et on a attendu la mort de pablo
escobar pour diffuser le son diffusé et
on regarde les images à londres c'est
justement dans la sierra qu'une équipe
de télévision française le retrouve au
détour d'un reportage
la rencontre est un scoop mondial la
première fois qu'un journaliste étranger
film le narcotrafiquant pablo escobar va
en profiter pour justifier son business
il faut être réaliste nous sommes en
train de vivre la civilisation de la
cocaïne
la cocaïne est en train d'envahir le
monde pourquoi est-elle en train de
l'envahir parce qu'elle est une drogue
- forte moins nuisible que d'autres le
problème des drogués est un problème de
manque d'éducation et de discipline
reportage qui a fait date c'est en 1989
avec un scoop mondial encore une fois
vous allez continuer à faire des scoops
un petit peu ce genre pas toujours au
même niveau ou bien sûr encore trois ans
à tf1 qui vous allez arrêter
on va voir pourquoi vous avez arrêté
comment ça se passe après la vie après
tf1 c'est dans une autre pièce que ça se
passe mais lettonie
[Musique]
et oui tony dernière dernière pièce la
piste de la modernité et de l'avenir et
justement vous quitter tf1 et vous
lancer ça tony comiti productions
pourquoi après avoir passé 17 ans à tf1
de grands reportages
une envie de revenir indépendant voilà
de monter une entreprise sans vraiment
vouloir on est dans une une entreprise
cod au départ c'est l'histoire de
copains cette agence c'est elle démarre
dans ma cuisine avec un photographe qui
s'appelait patrick chauvel et un grand
inconfort porter et puis on a eu des
commandes sont interdites envoyé spécial
et et puis ma femme m'a viré de la
cuisine parce qu'elle me dit bon je
commence à en avoir marre de tous ces
reporter avec leurs bêtes pleines de
boue qui y laissent leur vélo dans la
chambre donc j'ai déménagé et puis on a
monté mais voilà c'est une histoire de
copains
c'est une histoire design méditer en
fait c'est simplement d'avoir la liberté
de faire ce que vous voulez et le vendre
à toutes les chaînes vous vendez à tf1
rêvant d air france 2 prend 5 francs 5
w9 etc je vous avais une banque de
données et non comme vous avez deux fils
de 2000 remportée il ya 2000 reportage
entoure les moindres il ya cinquante
personnes 5 en faire s'est dirigée par
patrice louinet qui est d'origine
domaine et donc qui est un ancien
monteur de 52 sur la une donc ça parle
pas corse mais varia si l'agencé tony
comiti productions justement vous êtes
le deuxième producteur français au
niveau européen vous êtes classé et donc
parmi tous ces films la kia y en a qui
me plaît bien on va regarder c'est le
premier ont le regard parce qu'il a
voulu une véritable histoire on regarde
les petits vieux l'avait baptisé
angelito le petit ange
et ce petit ange avait réussi à
entraîner avec lui quelques autres
gamins ils étaient une douzaine à venir
faire le ménage apporter de la
nourriture ou tout simplement un peu de
réconfort
c'est incroyable ce gamin 9 ans qui
s'occupait des vieillards de son binôme
il
leur donner à manger ils élaborent un
bon et le lundi matin s'est pas loupé il
ya eu 700 mille francs de dons ce qui
ferait aujourd'hui cent mille euros qui
sont arrivés dans la semaine pour aider
ce petit gamin et du coup aujourd'hui
angelito le un an plus tôt ces puces est
toujours à petit en chef qu'il a un
hôpital aujourd'hui en colombie c'est
une rencontre formidable parce que moi
je démarre comme indépendant à nouveau
je suis affirme qu'ils seront dans le
monde entier et lui ça lui sert derrière
avec les dons bon évidemment il n'a pas
pu les gérer c'est l'ambassade de france
lui l'algérie
l'argent est aujourd'hui il dirige un
hôpital avec les 3 2 outre son vieux
quai vieux qui s'occupait l'inde
auspices au pied du bidonville
voilà ça c'était première remarque à
rennes rencontre qu'on verrait d'un très
beau reportage
et puis surtout tony comiti basse et sa
toile et committee c'est une signature
c'est une caméra à l'épaule ça c'est les
routes de l'impossible quand même ce
n'est un 56 routes de l'impossible tôt
fait que vous avez filmé lisant ça fait
dix ans qu'on vit au 10e rang des saints
dans le monde entier vous rendez sur
japon est une entreprise florissante
sodiko me tient vraiment oui florissante
florissante c'est un grand mot on essaye
de en fait on retrouve l'argent nous
donne les chaînes sur l'écran parce que
ça coûte cher de produire
voilà donc mais ce qui est et ce qui est
intéressant notamment dans les routes de
l'impossible c'est qu'il ya c'est
l'exportation du savoir faire français
les reporter français ou un vrai
savoir-faire différence des anglo saxons
qui filme la une interview a été mille
fois copié mais jamais égalé fils
vous avez raison les routes de
l'impossible c'est un stade entier
cédant volonté marche très bien et ça
c'est une signature cette fois ci c'est
tony comiti mais autre chose aussi vous
avez ça aussi tony à gérard en le voyant
arriver les gens disent volontiers
voilà un homme qui a la tête sur les
épaules
ce corps robuste éloquent supporter une
tête coiffée ou décoiffer
deux mèches de copeaux d'herbe le propre
à l'adolescence se laisse pas filmer
concert gérard c'est quelqu'un de
compliqué d'ailleurs la première non pas
la première fois qu'on l'a pour parler
du projet il ya pour piper a été laissé
tout bécaud faut pas les il faut rien
faire
puis finalement il a accepté parce qu'il
est c'est l'amitié et encore c'est le
rapport que richard melloul hi ha avec
gérard donc ces voix-là histoire de
rencontre superbe documentaire qui va
vous falloir justement mais les
récompenses a commencé à commencer par
ça craint alors voilà à ce documentaire
vous allez faire les parages de cannes
alors quand vous étiez jeune vous alliez
t paparazzo avec l'autre côté de la
mariée côté de la barrière vient vous
montez les marches très impressionnant
très impressionnant le film est nommé à
cannes
donc c'est très impressionnant parce que
d'abord il ya une histoire d'amitié
entre richard et moi et puis voilà on se
retrouve à cannes quoi ou monter les
marches quoi donc avec gérard qui vous
avez dit faut pas y aller à cannes c'est
des cons faut pas gagner
il est allé lui même quelque chose à
cannes non non non sélectionné à cannes
historique non c'est une sélection par
contre ça par contre non parce que c'est
la même histoire j'ai l'impression les
emmy awards les emmy awards aux
etats-unis alors ça c'est pour un film
sur le chili celui quand vous retournez
voir les anciens bourreaux exactement
et puis avec eux le reportage de avec le
documentaire de depardieu vous allez
aussi aux emmy awards tout à fait on
essayait sénégal c'est mondial qu'est ce
qu'il a dit là depardieu pour ça faut y
aller
la foulée c'est pas des cons parce que
j'aimais bien dans quelque chose on en a
été nommé nommé là ici on a gagné un
emmy c'est sur le chenil et la dictature
au quotidien avec manuel arthuis qui est
un grand reporter aussi
voilà donc c'est très impressionnant
aussi très impressionnant parce que les
américains reçoivent avec beaucoup
d'amitié aussi très important on va sur
cet écran là si vous le voulez bien
parce que votre vie c'est aussi la
famille c'est la famille c'est mon fils
paul 47 ans aujourd'hui
des fois il a suivi à peu les traces
c'est à dire paul a eu son bac avec
mention au lycée henri iv et qu'en
juillet
coûte bac avec mention tu fais du
journalisme de sciences po je crois je
pense faire réfléchir et en fait il m'a
dit ce que je devrais faire c'est de
suivre un peu donc il a été mon
assistant pendant deux ou trois ans et
aujourd'hui c'est un grand porteur donc
un spécialiste de conflit ils reviennent
colombie d'ailleurs atteint voyez comme
quoi la labié étonnante éolien de
colombie où il a fait un documentaire
qui va passer sur enquête exclusive sur
m6 sur les héritiers des narcos voilà ah
oui vous avez fait pas moins ce qu il
fait les héritiers fils jaga piss christ
lui il est grand reporter il y en a même
qui fait de l'étude journalistes croient
et qui est en quête biologie et puis les
deux autres ben yahia qui vit en
colombie
voilà vous voyez comme quoi et puis
l'autre et au lycée et se prépare
probablement à partir un peu dans le
cinéma ou la caméra l'intéressent en
tout cas et tient la photo s'est mis
tout seul
pareil mais ça justement c'est avec avec
richard melloul le photographe de gérard
depardieu
on fait un peu de musique que ça de
temps en temps parce que j'ai pu
entendre qu'ils peu de musique
pas mal la web on se débrouille mais
papa c'est souvent parce que
le travail voilà donc on a un petit
groupe et on voulait beetle vraiment
fallu écouter aux emmy awards la
prochaine fois voilà c'est une passion
aussi la guitare parce que je quand
j'étais gamin je voulais devenir
musicien ou photo gr 2 l'avenir c'est
soit c'est plus la musique pourront
comprendre l'avenir c'est prendre plus
de temps pour faire de la musique avec
des copains voilà c'est plus avoir du
temps celles et ceux ci n'y tenons
lorsque je vous propose pour finir une
mission on skie pas comme ça non ce qui
toujours avec à celle ci a d'accord oui
c'est devenu une tradition dans
l'émission dont vous souriez comme ça
avec ap
il me reste à vous remercier à vous
signifier votre continuation
vous avez 67 ans mais vous n'êtes pas
prêt d'arrêter on est d'accord
j'arrêterai quand je serai vieux alors
là vraiment je reviens de réponse merci
merci' a voulu que merci à tout le monde
et bientôt et vous êtes du côté de sir
allan imagine jeumont taseer demain
matin
les pneus route ou d'un possible aussi
d'ailleurs un petit peu surtout le soir
qu'on te revient de boîte